the nfc i think other than okay the
cowboys out of the other teams we're
gonna talk about out of the teams in the
playoffs right now right 49ers packers
saints cowboys uh seahawks vikings i
have the most questions about the
packers still
i do i mean their defense is just i just
don't trust it and can aaron rodgers and
the run game just continue to carry them
and hide that defense i think it's very
scary it's a huge game coming up for
them on sunday night because after that
they go to the giants that's a game they
should win then they have washington
that's a game they should win then they
have the bears that's a game they should
win but i i think that the nfc north is
going to come down to the last two weeks
it's going to be packers at vikings in
the final monday night of this season
and then the vikings have the bears at
home and the packers have to go to
detroit they they may not have matthew
stafford available for the lions even
then but the packers don't automatically
win in detroit no right the duck the
lions are going to give him a heck of a
time it's a great opportunity to lay the
foundation for a good start next year
you spoil the packers season so the
packers could go into week 16
as the two seed and they could come out
of week 17 as the sixth seed you're
right they definitely can and like i
said i mean i don't like their ability
to stop a 49ers or a vikings offense
right now so that's scary now maybe they
get a break with matthew stafford like
you said being hurt and to where they
don't have to deal with him at the end
of the year because that would be
extremely dangerous as well but yeah i
just have questions about them just
because they've been a little all over
the map now they find ways to win the
game but i don't sit there and just feel
confident all the time about them the
saints uh gave us a scare last week with
that ugly loss to the atlanta falcons
but they got off the mat yesterday and
handled the tampa bay
they're hanging tough at eight and two
you mentioned the seahawks they were off
this week they have at philadelphia when
they return from nearby the one team
that stands out when you look at the six
teams currently in a playoff position
yeah they all have eight wins except for
the cowboys right but hey the cowboys
are at six and four they got a one game
lead now over the eagles i'm still not
sure the cowboys can hold it though yeah
because they have new england at new
england next week i think for the eagles
it's key to beat the seahawks at home
this weekend if they can beat the
seahawks they've got at the dolphins
giants at washington before their
showdown with the cowboys week 16. i
still think the eagles can win that
division yeah and if the cowboys don't
win the division they're not going to
the playoffs and if they don't go to the
playoffs jason garrett's going to be
gone yeah there's a lot riding on the
next six weeks for the dallas cowboys
and specifically for jason garrett there
definitely is and you know i know you
heard me say it earlier in the show
you know again i i don't think the run
game ezekiel is quite where i would like
it to be you know again i think ezekiel
has proven to be the fifth best running
back in football this year right now and
he's the highest paid one dak prescott's
been amazing the pass offense has been
amazing i worry about the defense i mean
again
you know driscoll and the detroit lions
went up and down the field on the dallas
cowboys once again to where i just i
don't know what to think of them uh and
i just don't feel like they've played
really great football ever since those
first three weeks of the year now i know
they've won some games since then but it
just hasn't been pretty and yeah them
having to go up to new england's gonna
be tough buffalo's gonna be tough the
week after you know and then you got
guys like you know the rams and the
eagles two of the last three weeks there
you know they're scary right now and
especially like i said the way the
defense is playing it's not dominant
teams seem to be moving the ball on that
dallas defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports